>> Will Sentance: Đây là phần cứng của JavaScript.
Những nền tảng chúng ta phải hiểu để có được Phần cứng
đôi khi sẽ cảm thấy một chút nhỏ nhặt, một chút tầm thường.
Tôi hy vọng bạn đã từng đến Hard Parts trước đây, bạn thậm chí sẽ cảm thấy, giữ chặt,
Tôi đã thấy những thứ này trước đây.
Khoảng 30 phút đầu tiên của chúng tôi sẽ là tài liệu,
nếu bạn đã đến Hard Parts trước đây, bạn sẽ nhận ra.
Vì đó là công cụ JavaScript và cách nó hoạt động,
nó phổ biến, nhưng chúng ta phải đặt ra những nền tảng này.
Và bằng cách bạn sẽ thấy mã nơi bạn sẽ đến,
vâng, cảm ơn.
Tôi hiểu mã này đang chạy như thế nào, tôi hiểu nó đang làm gì.
Nhưng chúng ta sẽ thấy nó,
và nó sẽ trao quyền cho chúng tôi sau đó giải quyết tất cả các phần khó khăn sắp tới.
Được rồi.
>> Will Sentance: Đi thôi, đây rồi.
Chúng tôi sẽ viết bảng trắng thông qua tất cả quá trình thực thi mã của chúng tôi giống như
công cụ JavaScript chạy nó.
Chúng tôi làm điều đó, không thể có lỗ hổng trong hiểu biết của chúng tôi.
Chúng tôi sẽ từng bước một, và
chúng tôi sẽ lập bản đồ nó trên bảng trắng toàn bộ thời gian.
Vì vậy, với suy nghĩ đó, điều gì sẽ xảy ra khi JavaScript thực thi, chạy mã của tôi?
Có hai nửa, và tôi sẽ nói ngay với bạn.
Có hai nửa của quá trình thực thi mã.
Một là khả năng đi qua từng dòng mã theo nghĩa đen.
Đó được gọi là luồng thực thi.
Và tất cả những điều đó là khả năng xử lý ở dòng một, hãy làm điều đó,
bất cứ điều gì nó nói để làm.
Lấy dòng hai, làm điều đó, bất cứ điều gì nó nói phải làm.
Đi dòng ba, làm điều đó, bất cứ điều gì nó nói.
Nó đang thực thi, viết mã, blah, blah và
nó phân luồng theo cách của nó xuống mã của chúng tôi.
Nhân tiện, theo thứ tự, từ trên xuống dưới.
Đồng thời, phần khác cần thiết để chạy mã của chúng tôi là một nơi
để lưu trữ các bit dữ liệu mà chúng tôi thông báo khi chúng tôi thực hiện mã của chúng tôi.
Vì vậy, bạn có thể thấy ở dòng một, chúng tôi đang thông báo,
sau đó chúng tôi sẽ lưu trữ num làm nhãn cho một số dữ liệu ba.
Và vì vậy chúng tôi sẽ lập bản đồ những thứ này trên bảng trắng,
đó sẽ là một trải nghiệm hấp dẫn.
Hãy xem cách nó đi từng dòng một, bắt đầu từ dòng một.
Tôi sẽ gọi cho Paul.
Chúng ta đang làm gì ở đây trong dòng một?
Chúng ta thực sự đang làm gì?
>> Paul: Chúng tôi đang nói rằng phân bổ một số dữ liệu cho toàn cầu
vào một hằng số được gọi là num, và sau đó ném một số nguyên 3 vào đó?
>> Will Sentance: Chà, đó có vẻ là một mô tả rất trực quan.
Vì vậy, chúng tôi đang ở trong trí nhớ của chúng tôi.
Trong bộ nhớ của chúng ta, chúng ta đang khai báo một hằng số.
Chỉ cần nhớ,
điều đó có nghĩa là một phần dữ liệu mà chúng tôi không được phép thay đổi vị trí của nó trong bộ nhớ.
Vì vậy, chúng ta không thể đột ngột thay thế giá trị của num bằng 4.
Nó hiện đã được thiết lập để chạy ứng dụng của chúng tôi,
num được đặt thành giá trị 3, tuyệt vời.
Michelle nói dòng mã tiếp theo của chúng ta ở đây muốn làm gì?
>> Paul: Dòng mã tiếp theo cũng đang tạo ra thứ gì đó trong bộ nhớ
chúng tôi đang gọi- >> Will Sentance: Được rồi mọi người
chúng tôi đang rất chính xác, điều này chính xác [LAUGH] đi tiếp nó được gọi là gì?
Gọi là đa dạng, xuất sắc. Được đặt tên là MultiBy2,
chúng tôi đang khai báo hàm NhânBy2.
Trong JavaScript, các hàm có nghĩa là toàn bộ
chức năng là giá trị được ký kết của chúng tôi.
Cũng giống như số 3 chúng tôi đang lưu trữ trong bộ nhớ, chức năng,
định nghĩa chức năng của MultipleBy2.
Tôi sẽ không viết toàn bộ định nghĩa hàm trên
phía bên phải ở đây.
Thay vào đó, tôi sẽ đại diện cho nó bằng chiếc hộp nhỏ này có chữ f trong.
Điều đó đại diện cho toàn bộ định nghĩa chức năng của tôi.
Nếu tôi làm trong bảng điều khiển của mình, bây giờ hãy ghi lại MultiBy2,
tôi sẽ thấy gì, James?
>> Paul: Bạn sẽ thấy mã nguồn thực sự của hàm.
>> Will Sentance: Đúng vậy. Tôi sẽ thấy chính khối mã
hàm nhânBy2.
Bạn biết đấy, tôi sẽ thấy toàn bộ mọi thứ với mã trong bảng điều khiển của mình.
Đó là những gì chúng tôi muốn nói khi chúng tôi nói khai báo một hàm.
Đôi khi chúng ta nghĩ hoặc chúng ta chỉ nghĩ rằng có một mã hoạt động, không có mã nào trong số đó.
Chức năng từ khóa theo nghĩa đen có nghĩa là lưu vào bộ nhớ,
lưu vào bộ nhớ chức năng cụ thể này.
Được rồi, tuyệt vời, dòng mã thứ ba của chúng ta thực thi những gì, Sean?
>> Sean: Nó hoạt động giống như khai báo hằng đầu tiên của chúng tôi,
chỉ tạo một phần bộ nhớ được gọi là tên, gửi nó đến a-
>> Will Sentance: Tuyệt vời,
Sean, đâu không phải dòng mã thứ ba của chúng ta?
>> Sean: kết quả const.
>> Will Sentance: Đúng, tại sao không?
>> Sean: Bởi vì điều đó vẫn chưa được gọi.
>> Will Sentance: Chính xác, chúng tôi không đi sâu vào nội dung của một hàm cho đến khi,
Sean?
>> Sean: Cho đến khi nó được gọi.
>> Will Sentance: Cho đến khi nó được gọi, xuất sắc.
Được rồi, Sean đang ở đó.
Và dân gian, điều này có vẻ tầm thường sâu sắc.
Được rồi, tôi biết cách lưu trữ nội dung trong bộ nhớ.
Nhưng nền tảng này là thứ chúng ta cần.
Mức độ chính xác này hoàn toàn quan trọng đối với mọi thứ sau đó,
tất cả các cách để xây dựng lại không đồng bộ đang chờ đợi với máy phát điện.
Tất cả cuối cùng phụ thuộc vào những nền tảng này.
Được rồi, xuất sắc.
Vì vậy, ngay sau khi chúng tôi bắt đầu chạy mã của mình, chúng tôi sẽ tìm ra hai thứ.
Một, khả năng xem qua từng dòng mã của chúng tôi.
Đó là quy trình thực hiện của chúng tôi.
Hãy nhớ rằng, xâu chuỗi theo cách của nó và thực thi từng dòng mã.
Và đồng thời, chúng tôi xoay tròn, nó ở ngay đó, chính sách thực thi là bạn mã hóa
từng dòng, một bộ nhớ trực tiếp của các biến với dữ liệu.
Một kho lưu trữ trực tiếp các nhãn với dữ liệu.
Tên vị trí cho đó là một môi trường biến đổi,
chúng ta có thể gọi nó là một môi trường biến đổi.
Hãy coi nó như bản thể, môi trường là những thứ xung quanh tôi.
Đây là những biến xung quanh tôi, môi trường biến đổi.
Bây giờ, hai nửa này cùng nhau đã được biết đến.
Hai nửa này cùng nhau, chủ đề của nó, chúng ta sẽ đi qua.
Chúng tôi không sao chép các dòng trong chủ đề, không có ý nghĩa gì cả.
Nhưng hai nửa này cùng nhau được biết đến như một bối cảnh thực thi.
Bối cảnh là không gian để làm điều gì đó, không gian của bối cảnh mà chúng ta làm điều gì đó
hoặc đó là không gian mà chúng ta thực thi mã của mình, đó là một ngữ cảnh thực thi.
Và đó là công cụ toàn cầu mà chúng tôi sẽ khám phá bất cứ khi nào bạn muốn chạy mã,
bao gồm cả ví dụ: khi chúng tôi muốn thực thi mã bên trong một hàm, chúng tôi
sẽ tạo một ngữ cảnh thực thi cục bộ nhỏ chỉ để chạy mã bên trong
một hàm, chúng tôi gọi đó là hàm cục bộ, chỉ cho nội dung bên trong hàm.
Vì vậy, điều này mặc dù là cho mã tổng thể của chúng tôi, nó được gọi là bối cảnh thực thi toàn cầu.
Tất cả những người phù hợp, chúng ta hãy xem.
Cái gì tiếp theo?
Được rồi, như Sean đã nói đúng, chúng tôi đã không thực hiện, chúng tôi đã không gọi,
chúng tôi đã không gọi ra MultiBy2, vì vậy chúng tôi đã ở trong bối cảnh thực thi nào, Sean?
>> Sean: Toàn cầu.
>> Will Sentance: Toàn cầu, xuất sắc, nhưng
bây giờ chúng ta sẽ thực thi một hàm và xem điều gì sẽ xảy ra.
Vì vậy, chúng tôi đã khai báo số ba, khai báo chức năng MultiBy2.
Dòng mã tiếp theo của chúng ta là gì?
Ông Henderson.
>> Brian Henderson: Vâng.
>> Will Sentance: Dòng mã tiếp theo của chúng ta là gì, Brian?
>> Brian Henderson: Chúng tôi đang tạo một nhãn mới trong bộ nhớ được gọi là đầu ra.
>> Will Sentance: Tuyệt vời, chúng ta đã biết những gì để gán cho nó chưa?
>> Brian Henderson: Nó vẫn chưa được xác định tại thời điểm này.
>> Will Sentance: Rất tốt.
Vì đâu là phía bên tay phải?
Phía bên tay phải có phải là giá trị mà chúng ta có thể lưu trữ không?
>> Brian Henderson: Không, nó đang gọi việc thực hiện-
>> Di chúc: Chính xác,
đó là một lệnh để đi và làm điều gì đó.
Nó thực sự không phải là một giá trị mà chúng ta có thể lưu trữ ở phía bên tay phải.
Đầu ra không có lãi suất trong MultiBy2.
Đó là một lệnh để đi và
chạy một số mã bất cứ điều gì được trả về được gọi là, những gì Brian?
Tên chung cho những gì được trả về ngoài chức năng?
>> Brian Henderson: Giá trị trả về.
>> Will Sentance: Trả lại giá trị, chính xác.
Theo nghĩa đen, giá trị trả về.
Đó là những gì sẽ được chỉ định cho đầu ra.
Được rồi, làm đi.
Vì vậy, đầu ra sẽ là kết quả,
giá trị trả về của việc gọi MultiBy2 với đầu vào là 4.
Vậy là xong, vậy tôi đã nói chúng ta tạo bất cứ khi nào có mã để thực thi?
Ban phước?
>> Ban phước: Nhìn vào bối cảnh hành quyết >> Di chúc: Bối cảnh hành quyết,
Tôi sẽ đại diện cho điều đó.
Đây là hộp lớn hơn với hai phần, tôi sẽ đại diện cho nó bằng một hộp nhỏ
với hai phần, nó đây.
Tôi đang thực hiện điều này một cách từ từ vì chúng thực sự là, trong 10, 15 phút tới,
chúng ta sẽ thấy ba phần thực thi JavaScript đồng bộ.
Nếu chúng ta không hạ được những phần này, thì không có gì khác xảy ra sau đó.
Vì vậy, vào bối cảnh thực thi này, chúng ta đi.
Và cũng giống như toàn cầu của chúng tôi để chạy mã chính, bây giờ chúng tôi sẽ chạy
mã cho chỉ bên trong MultiBy2, chúng tôi sẽ có một bộ nhớ nhỏ chỉ dành cho
mã, chỉ cho những thứ được công bố, được khai báo.
Các biến, hàm và tham số,
và các đối số được khai báo bên trong phần thân của MultiBy2.
Họ chỉ sắp xếp ở đây.
Nhân tiện, khi hàm này thực thi xong,
tất cả những mảnh đó, trừ khi chúng được trả lại,
sẽ tự động bị xóa, rác được thu gom.
Đó là những thứ mà chúng tôi không thể truy cập lại, chúng tôi không thể tham chiếu lại những tên đó, vì vậy
nó là rác.
Đó là bộ nhớ đang bị lãng phí.
Chúng tôi sẽ tự động xóa nó bằng JavaScript, được rồi,
ngoại trừ một điều kiện đặc biệt mà chúng ta sẽ thấy một chút sau.
Vì đó là thứ tôi thích nhất trong JavaScript,
những thời điểm khi tất cả dữ liệu của chúng tôi không nhất thiết phải
bị xóa khi chúng ta thoát khỏi một hàm, khái niệm đẹp nhất trong JavaScript.
Và mặc dù chúng tôi sẽ không xem nó như là tiêu điểm,
tất yếu chúng ta phải đến với nó, trong bán kính của nó.
Được rồi, tốt, vậy chúng ta bắt đầu.
Và điều đầu tiên là gì,
Rick, bên trong bối cảnh thực thi cục bộ mà chúng ta sẽ làm?
>> Rick: Định nghĩa một biến hằng số được gọi là kết quả.
>> Will Sentance: Vậy đó là điều thứ hai của chúng tôi, Rick.
Điều đầu tiên chúng ta đưa vào bộ nhớ cục bộ là gì?
>> Rick: Chức năng.
>> Will Sentance: Không phải là chức năng, Michelle?
>> Michelle: Số đầu vào.
>> Will Sentance: Chính xác, số đầu vào được gọi là tham số của chúng tôi,
ghi nhớ trình giữ chỗ.
Chúng tôi đã xác định một hàm có nghĩa là, chúng tôi sẽ chạy điều này sau.
Khi bạn điều hành tôi, hãy đảm bảo rằng bạn điền vào chỗ trống đó,
trình giữ chỗ đó và đặt số với một đối số.
Tham số là trình giữ chỗ.
Đối số là giá trị thực tế được chuyển vào.
Michelle, lập luận của chúng ta là gì?
>> Michelle: Đối số của chúng tôi là 4.
>> Will Sentance: Tuyệt vời, và kết quả là 8.
Và dòng cuối cùng của phần nội dung của hàm cho biết làm gì, Josh?
>> Josh: Trả lại 8?
>> Will Sentance: Để trả lại 8, tôi thích điều đó.
Trả về giá trị của kết quả, 8.
Nó không trả về kết quả.
Nó trả về giá trị của kết quả, là một số 8.
Tôi không thích nói kết quả trả về, nó có nghĩa là toàn bộ.
Đó là JavaScript xem kết quả trả về và đi, kết quả là gì?
8, được rồi, hoàn hảo.
Trả nó về đâu?
Tên của bạn là gì, dude?
>> Brady: Brady.
>> Will Sentance: Brady, xin lỗi Brady.
Brady, trở về đâu?
>> Brady: Đến đầu ra nhãn.
>> Will Sentance: Nhưng bối cảnh thực thi nào?
>> Brady: Toàn cầu.
>> Will Sentance: Chính xác là trên toàn cầu.
Trả lại 8 vào bối cảnh thực thi chung.
Nơi nó được lưu trữ trong đầu ra, hoàn hảo.
Dân gian, tôi biết điều này có vẻ thủ tục, nhưng tôi biết bạn có thể thấy điều này và
đi yeah, yeah, tôi hiểu rằng sản lượng sẽ là 8, tôi hiểu rồi.
Nhưng chúng ta cần có sự chính xác.
Vì vậy, bây giờ hãy chú ý, nhân tiện,
rằng chúng tôi không được phép chuyển sang dòng tiếp theo trong toàn cầu khai báo đầu ra
cho đến khi chúng tôi hoàn thành việc chạy MultiBy2 với đầu vào là bốn.
Chuỗi thực thi của chúng tôi, khả năng đi qua từng dòng mã.
Khi nào nó đã vào cột nhânBy2, nơi nó đã dành thời gian
lướt qua từng dòng mã, rồi nhấn vào từ khóa nào để thoát?
Từ khóa nào, Mike, nói để thoát?
>> Mike: Trở lại. >> Di chúc: Trở lại, và
nếu không có câu lệnh trả về ở đó, thì dấu ngoặc nhọn đóng ngụ ý
một lợi nhuận ngầm sẽ chèn trở lại cho chúng tôi.
Và ra, sự trở lại.
Nói cách khác, JavaScript, nó có thể làm bao nhiêu việc cùng một lúc?
Một, chủ đề của nó là số ít.
Nó sẽ không tiếp tục xuống mã toàn cầu trong khi chạy đồng thời
nhânBy2.
Nó gần như nói rằng, được rồi, chúng ta hãy tiếp tục đi xuống đây, và
tiếp tục ở đây đồng thời.
Uh-uh, một trong những điều tuyệt vời về JavaScript là nó rất
có thể dự đoán được vì nó luôn luôn là thứ này đến thứ khác theo thứ tự, từ trên xuống dưới.
Ít nhất là trong bản chất đồng bộ cốt lõi của nó.
Tất nhiên chúng ta sẽ thấy khi điều đó không áp dụng.
Vì vậy, JavaScript là đồng bộ.
Theo thứ tự, từ trên xuống dưới và đơn luồng.
Chúng ta không thể đột nhiên làm hai việc cùng một lúc.
Tuyệt vời, vì vậy bây giờ chúng ta quay trở lại bối cảnh thực thi toàn cầu.
Nơi chúng ta gặp phải khai báo đầu ra mới, giá trị đó sẽ là giá trị trả về
của một lệnh gọi hàm khác đến MultipleBy2.
Chúng tôi sẽ tạo bối cảnh thực thi cho nó.
Khi bắt đầu, điều đầu tiên, Rick, trong trí nhớ cục bộ của chúng ta là gì?
>> Rick: Số đầu vào.
>> Will Sentance: Cái nào được gọi là của chúng tôi?
Nhớ tên sang trọng cho một trình giữ chỗ?
>> Rick: Lập luận?
>> Will Sentance: Vì vậy, đó là đối số, đó là?
>> Rick: Thông số. >> Will Sentance: Tham số.
Được rồi, Rick, lập luận của chúng ta là gì?
Bạn đúng khi nói tham số của chúng tôi là số đầu vào.
Lập luận của chúng ta ở đây là gì?
>> Rick: 10.
>> Will Sentance: 10, xuất sắc.
Được rồi, kết quả sẽ là 20.
Và chúng tôi đưa nó trở lại toàn cầu.
20 được trả về hằng số chung, newOutput là 20.
Vì vậy, chuỗi của chúng tôi đã đi vào và lại đi ra ngoài.
>> Will Sentance: Được rồi, nhưng
có một phần cuối cùng cho mô hình JavaScript đồng bộ này.
Chúng ta có tên vị trí trong bộ nhớ, môi trường biến đổi.
Chúng tôi có chuỗi thực thi của mình,
khả năng đi qua từng dòng mã.
Chúng được gọi là bối cảnh thực thi.
Hai thứ chúng ta cần để thực thi mã.
Bối cảnh mà chúng ta cần, bối cảnh của những thứ chúng ta cần để thực thi mã.
Nhưng chúng tôi đã tạo ra một loạt các bối cảnh thực thi này,
đã xóa, đã tạo.
Và sau đó, chúng tôi chạy một chức năng khác bên trong chức năng đó,
đó là một chiếc mini nhỏ khác đang được tạo ra bên trong đó.
Theo dõi những người đó đối với chúng tôi dễ dàng trực quan.
Tôi đã hoàn thành mã hóa MultiBy2.
Tôi thoát ra khỏi nó, và tôi đã trở lại như trước đây khi tôi bắt đầu viết mã MultiBy2.
Chúng ta có thể thấy điều đó một cách trực quan rất dễ dàng.
JavaScript không có khả năng nhìn thấy trực quan giống như trước đây, tôi đã gọi
chức năng này trong toàn cục và tôi đã ở trong hộp lớn khi tôi chuyển nó sang hộp nhỏ.
Khi tôi hoàn thành từ hộp nhỏ, tôi quay trở lại hộp lớn.
JavaScript không có khả năng đó.
Nó cần theo dõi vị trí của nó trong mã ngay bây giờ,
nó ở đâu trước khi nó bắt đầu ở bên trong chức năng này,
nơi nó sẽ quay trở lại khi kết thúc bên trong chức năng này.
Cái gì, đây là một thứ kiến ​​thức, có ai biết dữ liệu gì không,
chúng tôi có thể lưu trữ loại thông tin đó ở bất kỳ định dạng nào.
Nhưng có một cấu trúc đặc biệt đẹp,
cách cấu trúc dữ liệu sẽ lưu trữ thông tin đó rất rõ ràng.
Có ai biết cấu trúc đó có thể là gì không?
>> Michelle: Ngăn xếp.
>> Will Sentance: Nó là một ngăn xếp.
Chính xác, trên thực tế, nó sẽ là một đống cuộc gọi.
Một ngăn xếp là a, chúng ta có các mảng.
Mảng nói,
danh sách dữ liệu mà tôi có thể lấy một phần tử ở bất kỳ vị trí ngẫu nhiên nào.
Điều đó không phản ánh những gì chúng tôi muốn làm ở đây.
Ở đây, chúng tôi muốn nói, giống như một chồng đĩa.
Tôi đặt cái đầu tiên vào, tôi bắt đầu trong bối cảnh thực thi toàn cầu,
đó là phần tử đầu tiên của tôi trong ngăn xếp của tôi.
Và sau đó khi tôi bắt đầu chạy MultiBy2, tôi thêm nó lên trên.
Và điều đó giống như việc thêm đĩa tiếp theo của tôi.
Nếu tôi phải chạy một chức năng khác bên trong đó, tôi sẽ thêm chức năng đó lên trên.
Khi tôi hoàn thành cái đó, tất cả những gì tôi quan tâm là khi tôi cất cái đó đi,
cái trước đã có trước đó vẫn ở đó,
và đó là bản chất của một ngăn xếp.
Đó là khi tôi lấy đi thứ cuối cùng còn sót lại,
Tôi trở lại nơi tôi trước đây.
Và vì vậy một ngăn xếp sẽ là một ngăn xếp các lệnh gọi đến các hàm.
Bắt đầu, đây là ngăn xếp cuộc gọi, ngăn xếp cuộc gọi đến các hàm.
Bắt đầu với loại đại diện của tổng thể của chúng tôi,
hãy nghĩ về toàn bộ cơ sở mã như một hàm được gọi là toàn cục, nhưng
ngay sau khi chúng tôi bắt đầu chạy mã của mình, chúng tôi đang chạy toàn cầu.
Vì vậy, hãy bắt đầu với toàn cầu ngay khi chúng tôi bắt đầu chạy mã của mình.
Khi chúng ta bắt đầu chạy MultiBy2.
>> Will Sentance: Paul, nó có ý nghĩa gì với ngăn xếp cuộc gọi của chúng tôi?
>> Paul: Thêm vào bối cảnh thực thi mới.
>> Will Sentance: Thêm vào ngữ cảnh thực thi mới, chính xác.
Thêm vào lệnh gọi nhânBy2 với đầu vào là 4.
Có nghĩa là khi tôi đang ở trong hàm MultiBy2, chuỗi của tôi
nằm trong hàm MultiBy2 của tôi, MultiBy2 sẽ đứng đầu trong đống lệnh gọi của tôi.
Một quy tắc đơn giản của tôi là, bất kể điều gì ở đầu ngăn xếp cuộc gọi của tôi,
đó là nơi tôi đang ở ngay bây giờ.
Và sau đó, ngay khi tôi trở ra, điều gì sẽ xảy ra, Paul, với ngăn xếp cuộc gọi của tôi?
>> Paul: multipleBy2, bối cảnh thực thi đó biến mất.
Bạn quay trở lại toàn cầu, và sau đó bạn- >> Will Sentance: Tuyệt vời,
Tôi sẽ loại bỏ MultiBy2 khỏi ngăn xếp cuộc gọi của mình.
Và chúng ta có thể biết, do đó quay trở lại bối cảnh thực thi toàn cầu như một đầu ra, nhưng
JavaScript thì không.
JavaScript biết điều đó vì hãy nhìn vào ngăn xếp cuộc gọi của tôi bây giờ?
Đừng hoảng sợ.
Nó toàn cầu và trở lại toàn cầu.
Điều này cho phép JavaScript theo dõi vị trí của nó trong mã của nó,
dòng nào đang chạy và sau đó khi tôi kết thúc trong bối cảnh thực thi hiện tại,
tôi sẽ quay trở lại đâu?
Nó sẽ thoát khỏi vị trí của tôi, và
lớp tiếp theo xuống là nơi tôi quay lại.
Được rồi.
Nhân tiện, tên sang trọng cho
thêm vào một ngăn xếp không phải là thêm, không phải là ném tiếp, là những gì Sean?
Victor? Tên sang trọng để thêm vào ngăn xếp là gì,
có ai biết không
>> Victor: Đẩy đi. >> Will Sentance: Đẩy,
đó là thuật ngữ kỹ thuật khoa học máy tính để thêm vào một ngăn xếp.
Và cái tên sang trọng, Josh, bạn biết đấy, để lấy thứ gì đó ra khỏi ngăn xếp?
>> Josh: Bốp. >> Will Sentance: Pop, chính xác,
đẩy và bật.
Tuyệt vời, được rồi, tốt.
Đúng, chúng tôi đã nói về điều này.
Vì vậy, chúng ta hãy biết những nền tảng cốt lõi này.
Ngón tay cái là một kỹ thuật sư phạm được sử dụng rộng rãi để chỉ ra sự hiểu biết của một người.
Ngươi đánh mất ta, ta rất rõ ràng, ta có câu hỏi làm rõ.
Mọi người đều thích, ngay bây giờ.
Không sao để có lời giải thích rõ ràng.
Không ai?
Rất, rất bực bội.
Được rồi, tốt, tốt.